hello everyone today mark and I would
love to show you a little bit of how its
what it's like to explore dreams on
PlayStation 4 live for the first time
outside our little studio and so dreams
is a game designed to unleash your
creativity to turn the ps4 into the
creative console the game is still in an
alpha state so this is probably going to
go completely wrong but we felt the best
way to update you was just to play boss
warp ree live it arrum every player gets
to create their own customized imp who
goes everywhere with you in dreams you
use your imp to explore communicate with
the people and characters that you meet
so imps are very nimble they follow your
movement with the controller exactly a
mark can even change their expression
drawing a new mouth shape with the
touchpad on the DualShock controller so
as well as exploring you can use them to
grab pull and poke at the world it's
very direct tactile and intuitive let's
move a few of these shapes either way
here this ball looks a little bit bouncy
yep there we go get back to the way
heavy-looking
if we can just move that out of the way
there go and take a look through this
door so many people have asked us what
does it actually like to play dreams
today we'd like to show you focusing on
two things firstly on characters hello
and a thing see if I can take you over
so much in dreams your imp can possess
characters vehicles or even inanimate
objects and marks it's gonna have a
little wand around this level and when
he possesses the character you can
directly move it like a puppet as you
can see it's very easy to be expressive
emotive it's just fun messing around
peekaboo
Thanks the second thing we want to talk
about is how we mash up creation and
gameplay so the owner of this particular
dream has decided to set all the
gameplay rules so that we can create
whatever we like each one can be
different each dream can go from
traditional platforming to racing to
sandboxes puzzles and of course making
things you're just gonna stand a few
trees down here and make this into a
more kind of spooky forest or something
the owner of this beam has left things
wide open and so mark can do whatever he
likes and he'll just showing you how
easy it is to make a level out of
pre-existing assets but of course in
dreams you can create remix and sculpt
your own well we won't go into that
today we go I'm just gonna wander back
down here and there's a rather exciting
looking item there some kind of house or
[ __ ] put one of those there investigate
okay there's a door what do you think
Alex should go in goal not take the
plunge I'm a little bit scared
okay so dreams endure sorry in in dreams
doors are very special things they can
lead you two completely different places
each time you use them and this one is
leading us on a story okay let's have a
little explore here so if we can find
anything of interest in dreams almost
anything whether it's a manhole cover a
well a clearing in a forest can be a
gateway to another dream what's this
witchcraft this okay nothing there but
that up there looks rather suspicious I
think we should probably be heading up
there the author of this dream is
completely locked it down they haven't
given us anything to create with so Marc
can't craft some steps to get up there
he'll have to have a look around and
find something hidden
okay well this this looks like a rather
obvious little spot to investigate um
actually before I do that I'm gonna just
do a little bit of
- cat host I'll graffiti here
come on mol we've got a demo to get on
with my best effort
okay let's know to try grabbing this yes
Hey here we go into the lights little
bit spooky what's this oh my lord
the size of this thing
if we can get get its attention hello
okay that's not working so let's try
this like it look at this I am Mighty
Mouse the characters are the best way to
get around in dreams and there are
literally going to be thousands to play
because they're really easy to customize
and create and we reckon the variety is
going to be like nothing else
any proportions any costume you can
imagine from Francis a tiny Panda to
this grumpy old huge Mouse in dreams
it's possible well hopefully book it's
got some kind of Revelation in it here
we go yes some kind of balloon Lantern
thing okay so I think it's pretty
obvious what we need to use those for so
I'm gonna head back the way we came here
leave him there go back to this little
fella scamper back over here maybe a
little wave goodbye and then
and if I remember rightly just around
this corner yes platform and obvious
little clue there so that's some bring
our point of entry I think that's our
ticket thought you've seen us here here
do today is play a really simple dream
both with our imp and by possessing
characters but the amazing thing to
remember is that everything here was
created completely from scratch using
the PlayStation 4
no pre-made assets no factory presets
the loan only limitations are those of
your imagination and if you play
LittleBigPlanet you remember that play
and create was separate but this game is
all about mashing them together and it's
even better when you take it online and
when we will practice in this last part
of the demo Maya and John join mark and
then completely ignored the level and
ignored my script they just messed
around and ended up having a load of fun
and I think that really captures dreams
at its best it's joyful exploration its
open-ended and who knows what
experiences lie and wait once you all
get to play it we certainly can't wait
thank you
please welcome to the stage Shuhei
Yoshida